I don't want to see.
I'm going to turn into a rock.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
Now, in Greek mythology,
Perseus used his sword
to decapitate Medusa
and remove her head from her
body to use it as a weapon.
To that end,
I will take your weapon
to help me deliver
some killing slashes
and blows to liberate
her head from her body.
Robert, you're up first.
You ready for this?
-Yes, sir.
-Let's do this.
Going into the testing,
I am concerned about the weight.
I'm hoping my blade
can do everything
that Doug wants it to do,
but I'm concerned.
All right, Robert. Let's talk
about your sword here.
I like the design that you have
of the Damascus in there.
But it's so heavy.
It's about 5 pounds over here.
But the thing is,
it's so forward heavy.
Most of the weight is up here.
When I'm lifting this,
I can feel all the stress
right there.
This is supposed to be meant to
be a single-handed use weapon.
Now, your edge is plenty sharp.
It was easy to thrust and cut,
and it will kill.
All right, Jared. Your turn.
Are you ready, sir?
-Yes, sir.
-Let's do this.
With the test, you never really
know what to expect,
and anything can go wrong.
All right, Jared. First up,
you nailed the balance on this.
It's a one-handed swords.
It's about 3 pounds lighter
than your opponent's.
Your edge is razor sharp.
Every slash is deep.
The thrust, no issues at all.
And most importantly, sir,
it will kill.
All right, bladesmiths.
Next up is the strength test.
Release the J. Neily.
All right, bladesmiths.
We took Medusa's head
during the kill test.
Now the kraken
has turned to stone.
So what I'm going to do
is take your swords
and beat them mercilessly
into these stone kraken heads.
It's going to be brutal.
And, Rob, you're up first.
How are you feeling?
A little nervous, but I'm ready.
-Let's do it.
-This is the make or break test.
You okay?
Yep. Bounced off the glove.
Didn't cut me.
-Well, that's that.
-My blade breaks.
My heart breaks, but I am just
so glad that it didn't hurt J.
Well, a little bit
of a problem here, Rob.
On the tang,
you can see a black spot,
so that means you had
a stress fracture there.
And with the weight
of this sword
hitting the stone kraken skulls,
it was enough to allow
that stress fracture
to just continue
all the way across it.
So the good part
is that your edge held up,
so good job on the Damascus,
but it's kind of hard to swing
a sword without a handle on it.
Well, Robert, your blade
broke after four strokes
on this kraken head,
but that doesn't mean that
you're out of the competition.
Jared, your blade still
has to survive four strikes.
J, let's get crack-a-lacking.
This is it right here.
I see what it did
to Rob's blade.
My sword has got to hold up
four swings, and I know J.,
he's going
to try to do some damage.
Jared, your blade survived.
Robert, unfortunately,
your blade cannot continue to be
tested in this competition,
and for that reason,
I have to ask you
to please leave the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
You killed the Medusa though.
It's a heartbreaker, but I'm
really proud of what I did.
Jared, congratulations.
The strength of your weapon
has ensured that you are
the "Forged in Fire" champion
leaving this forge with a check
for $10,000. Good job, brother.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you.
-How you feeling right now?
-Good.
-How about a smile or something?
-Yeah.
All right. Come on over
and shake our hands, brother.
-Thank you.
-Good job, man. Good game.
I am the new "Forged in Fire"
champion,
something
I never thought I'd say.
I can't wait to get home,
give my daughters the news
and take the $10,000,
take my family on a vacation
somewhere.